OVERTIME BY
AND THE HAD A PLAYOFF
INLE GETTING A PUCK OUT
OF THERE. LINE, SMITH.
AND THE IN REBOUND BY LINDGREN.
CACA THE NET,
MAN, HE'S GOT SOME SKILL.
HE JUST ON BY
MOTTEENSIVE END.
HERE'S
SEAN: A CHANCE FOR
ZIBANEJAD RIPPED D
SEAN: RIGHT BACK
TRADE OFF THE BACK WALL BY TROUN
IT POINT-BH LUCK
CONTINUES.
BUT THIS IS THE THIRD POWER PLAY
TWO-ON-ONE FOR
TROCHECK. ON THE NET
TROU
TROUBA KNOCKS IT DOWN TRIED TO Y
RIGHT AROUND BY SHESTYORKIN.
AND FROM THE SIDE OF THE CIRCLE
AND HELD BY IGOR FOR FOX TO LEAT
OF THE NET AND COME OUT THIS FAL
STRENGTH AS THE SECOND PERIOD PK
FOR STAAL.
STAAL CENTERS FROM A VERY TOUGH
AINGE 8 AND FROZEN B BSHOT DEFLT
OF
PASS.
A GOOD PLAY BY K'ANDRE 1-0, CAR.
THROUGH THE FEET OF SEBASTIAN
DEANGELO, A BEAUTIFULSEAN: THATE
UNTIL THIS POSTSEASON.
BIGOMES
BACK -- THIS IS TO